Iznogoud j'suis entrain de nous préparer un ptit before d'apéro à base de tomates cerises, tu m'en diras des nouvelles
Outch! oh nan j'me suis coupé ça pisse le sang, j'vais crever c'est excellent
Camille tu veux ... Oh! attend refais voir  - Quoi ça ? - ouais refais encore - comme ça ? - Ouais encore comme ça -  Ah nan j'suis entrain de me vider , tu veux pas appeler une ambulance ?
Attend, tu veut pas d’abord  qu'on organise un petit vernissage ?  J'adore le concept !
*Grincement de stylo*
A ouais ! Excellent !
-P*tain, j'ai la dalle ! Iznogoud ?   -Ouais ?   -Qu'es ce que tu nous a mijoté de bon ?
Bah écoute chui un peu charette donc j'ai fait ce qui m'est venu sur le pouce euh donc c'est :
un filet d’Alaska des Baltique...   -Wouaw !   -Cuisiné à la sauce citronnelle...  -Énorme !   -et doré à la panure de guérande.   - J'adore !
Wouaw, c'est excellent !
hey, énorme ta board, on échange ?
J'adore le concept !
Ça vient d’où ? Ça vient de Californie ? Have a nice day !
Attends mais là je comprend ap!
Tu commprend ap ?
Bah non !
Bah c'est une soirée tenu top secrète j'viens de recevoir l'invit' par sms et là d'après Google map, on devrait être arrivés !
Bah là il y a carrément un problème, soit c'est pas du tout ici soit on est carrément en avance !
A moins que ...
Noooooooooooooooooon .....
J'adore le concept !
Ouais, c’est clairement excellent !
Son dernier tableau était carrément à c****
Bon je vais aller la coucher c'est l'heure de la sieste
Bah attend te dérange pas on peux s'en occuper !
Mais carrément, tu dois en avoir mare ! T'inquiètes pas, on gère
Bien sur !
ok .
Tu nous entend, le blizzard , tu nous entend ? Si tu nous entend, va te faire e****** ! E****** ! A vous !
Elle est pas très réceptive à ...
Ouais carrément .
*En Anglais* : "Now is the winter, of our discounted ."
*En Anglais* : "May glorious seamer by this scener fiourc ."
A excellent
A elle parle pas, elle parle pas anglais ?
A autant pour moi .
C'est ridicule .
Elle parle quelle langue, du coup ?
J'adore ce Bpm !
C'est excellent !
P***** mais c'est qui ce mec ?
Je sais pas qui c'est mais il me faut sont album, clairement !
Emm, le concert est pas commencé les gars .
En fait, tu m’emmène où Iznogoude ?
Tu vas voir c'est un barbecue .
Whouaw
Ok whouaw y a que des hipsters
Alors moi, je ne traine pas avec les hipsters, c'est mort je préfère encore aller au badaboum, j'me casse.
Clairemment, whouaw, ok d'accord, whouaw
Whouaw, t'a vu les deux hipsters qui viennent de rentrer là ?
Attendez , nan mais pour qui ils se prennent?
Monsieur.
Je peux vous aider ?
yes
Euu, well
je recherche du café bio
Décaféiné
Évidemment issu de l'agriculture coopérative
Et si possible avec un petit gout mentholé .
Du thé, quoi .
Ouais, ouais du thé , du thé mais alors sans théine .
Alors, il y a peut-être quelque chose qui pourrait vous convenir a ce moment la y a pas de caféine, y a pas de théine qui est très bien,
C'est l'eau chaude.
Bonsoir messieurs, je peux vous aider ?
Non y'a pas de " je peux vous aider" ou quoi que ce soit vous savez pas qui on est, on a un blog, donc on se
Attend calme toi, calm down. On est sur liste au nom de Iznogoude et Camille, on est invités par Cassiopé et voila, y'a pas d'embrouille.
Je suis désolé messieurs mais y a pas de liste ici c'est une entré libre, allez y .
A ok je vois le délire, c'est une soirée open entrée, j'adore le concept.
Dans ce cas la c'est excellent, bonne soirée.
( Télé )
( Rires )
La tu vois gloria c'est notre perspective de Romère, romère un génie du cinéma.
Ouais, on peut le dire, ouai. Bon bah là c'est clairement une scène un peu "porn", c'est sa période ''nouvelle vague''.Un peu cul, mais pas trop, c'est excellent.
P***** mais vous êtes malade les mecs, c'est une enfant !
ben quoi ?
Apparemment, elle adore le concept !
Abonne-toi à nos chaines youtube en cliquant sur nos p***** de têtes tu va adorer c'est énormissime .
c'est excellent !
Sous titres by Wolfenstein's gamer